we are going to talk about explanations
of a black box AI systems right so we
have a black box system it does some
magic inside
and it gives us an output how do we know
that this output is actually correct if
you know the system installed in our
self-driving car is not recognizing the
obstacles correctly we're gonna crash
I'm sure that you know many people maybe
you're one of them who are very
concerned about this Prospect of using
self-driving cars I'm personally not but
I'm a computer scientist I think you
know I trust technology my AI much more
than I trust people but that's that's a
side note but many people will just
absolutely not trust the self-driving
car so hopefully an explanation of why
it behaves the way it does would help us
to to trust the system more
there is not always a direct link
because I think that for example when
we're going to see a doctor maybe we
transfer doctor more because they're
very distinguished and they have a wall
full of diplomas you know behind them
and not necessarily because they explain
you all the intricacies of the treatment
that they prescribe for you but in
general I think the explanations are
really helpful for the users to trust
and to be more confident in the AI
systems that they're going to use and of
course we need to know whether they are
correct
um in order you know to debug them and
fix them you know in case they're not in
general like any system we use would
like to know that that is correct right
it's working correctly at least most of
the time
so
um in case we have this black box here
system you know this is not a black box
but imagine this is the Box
and I feed something in so maybe I feed
uh this picture of panda
and it tells me it's a red panda
so how do I know so it does seem like a
red panda how do I know that it made the
decision from the right reasons
and not because it says red panda on
Mondays
or they're not because anything with the
blue sky is a red panda right or
anything with a tree's background just
suddenly red panda
so how do we know that so an explanation
method that I'm proposing to you does
not involve opening the Black Box
luckily so I'm opening only to get piece
of cardboard but actually I'm going to
keep the Black Box closed
I don't really don't want to look inside
and the reason I don't want to look
inside is because a it's complicated
B if I'm looking inside the number line
on a particular architecture number of
layers the neurons and if somebody
brings me another black box for this
purpose I won't be able to look inside
anymore
um so and sword actually because the
systems these black boxes they designed
not to for us not to look inside right
they train themselves you know you feed
them training data they somehow tune all
these neurons inside with the layers God
knows what
um and then at the end they say that
they're trained and they will give us
the output so let's try to get an
explanation without opening the black
box so I have this panda in front of me
and now I'm going to play with this
image this is how I'm going to
um construct an explanation first of all
I'm starting to cover parts of the panda
with the cardboard so what happens if I
cover this part this is probably no
longer a panda right this is not about
that uh what happens if I cover this
part oh that's still a panda right so
this part was not not essential for it
to be a panda okay let's now try to
decompose
the top one
so we're covering now lesser areas of
the panda
okay right so if we cover only this one
it's still a panda if we cover only this
one
it's still a panda but if we cover those
two it's no longer panda
so those two have some influence on the
fact that it was classified as a panda
more formally what we're going to do is
we are going to find a minimal subset of
the image of the area of of this pixels
of the image that is sufficient for the
for the AI system to recognize the same
which as a panda
and we're going to do it iteratively by
throwing away the areas that actually
are not relevant for it being opened up
and refining gradually refining the
areas that had some influence on it
being a pandem so at the end we have
this so this was covered with gray
cardboard with a particular color of
cardboard doesn't matter and we see that
the part that was minimal and sufficient
for it to be recognized as a panda is a
part large part of Panda's head so right
effectively we can cover everything
and which would be the same as a human
right which will be the same as a human
see some shadows and not know what it is
but the moment we see that face I
completely agree with you and this is
actually how we propose to check uh
sanity of those explanations right if
I'm looking at this and saying yeah it
makes sense right this is bundle's face
I mean I'm not a a biologist
um not as old just
um but yeah it seems to me like a
panda's face and indeed this is how I'm
going to to say okay this network I said
that it's a red panda for the right
reasons and not because today is Monday
I have more
um cute pictures right so this is a
Welsh Springer Spaniel uh energy that
was recognized as well Springer Spaniel
using the same method with a cardboard
this is the area this is the minimal and
sufficient for it to be recognized
as a Welsh Springer Spaniel now we're
getting to another very interesting
application
um of those explanations and this one is
to uncover misclassifications
so of course so I'm looking at this
picture this is a child wearing a cowboy
hat had it been recognized as a panda we
would immediately say no that's nonsense
in this particular case a black box AI
system or a neural network that we run
on it recognized it as a cowboy hat
which actually seems okay
right I mean it is possible that this
picture is labeled as carbohat it can be
the child or kabukat but you know
kabukat is a perfectly legal output but
then we try this explanation method so
we started covering it throwing away the
irrelevant parts of the image and this
is an explanation we came up with so
this part of the image was
a minimal part that is sufficient for it
to be recognized as a cowboy hat okay
that's obviously wrong
right that's a phase that's not a hat
so what happened here so there are
several things that we can infer from
this misclassification
one that obviously network is wrong
right there is a there is an error two
that
um it instead of a carbohydrates it
can't recognize faces
and three the from two we can infer that
our training set
was not built correctly specifically
images labeled as carbohydrates were all
of people wearing copperheads
and now we we even know how we can fix
it so how can we fix it very simply by
introducing more images of just
cardboard hats without you know people
wearing them just cover head on the
table Cabo hat on the hangar on the hook
Etc now we wanted to check the sanity of
our explanations are they stable at all
what happens if I take this Panda that
was sitting on a tree and put it
somewhere else
will the explanation still take a part
of the panda so we took this Panda we
cut a part that contained an explanation
remember explanation was part of Panda's
head we glued it on top of other images
so here is our roaming panda
um visiting the Eiffel Tower the moon
this is very far roaming Panda Natural
History Museum the Giza Pyramid and
having somebody's backyard every one of
these images was labeled as a panda in
the output of the Black Box air system
and indeed the explanations were part of
the Panda's head
which means that yes our technique works
it works correctly
and the fact that that we found this
minimal sufficient subset actually
definitely is not dependent on the panda
sitting on a tree in the bright sunlight
with the blue sky how many images do you
send through this to test whether the
test is right oh thousands testing the
test I suppose yes yes testing the test
yes thousands so we said we tested the
whole image net
um when covered several interesting
misclassifications similar to kabukat
none of them were that photogenic there
was something that was recognized as
wool because of the texture so no
nothing that that interesting
um but but yes most of them were
recognized correctly which is definitely
not a feature of explanations but the
feature of the AI system so their system
worked well most of the time and
explanations actually much much our
intuition and then with this we did it
with several images so we just like the
panda most so that's why we took the
roaming Panda but this just make to make
sure that that it passes the sanity to
check let's now talk a little bit about
explanations produced by these
techniques versus explanations generated
by humans
so I have a starfish here
if I ask you or the viewer why is it a
starfish what would you say well it's
the shape right it's the shape yes it
has you know five arms
um but now I'm asking you so what is a
minimal area of this image that is
sufficient for you to realize that it's
a starfish
yeah good question very good question so
probably thinking about this cardboard
technique I will start covering it we
will soon discover that there is a
symmetry to this shape and actually I'm
saying well it's a starfish because of
probably you know I see I'm seeing these
two two arms and yeah this is this is
enough for it to be starfish right so
this I'm covering the rest
I will still think that that's a selfish
right
but it is a symmetrical shape
therefore
this is also probably an explanation of
why it's a starfish
so we need multiple explanations in some
cases in case there is a symmetry a
human will give multiple explanations
and again we are in the realm of
increasing trust we do expect our system
to be capable of giving multiple
explanations this is definitely an
important goal not only to increase
trust but also because symmetry is an
important feature of some of the shapes
just from biological perspective so the
fact that this is a symmetric shape
might must be crucial might be crucial
for it to be recognized as a starfish
but it's not the Symmetry itself is it
obviously we've probably all seen
starfish with a missing leg right yeah
yeah but there's still a starfish
exactly exactly but you don't need it to
be symmetrical for it to be recognized
it's just the Symmetry helps you to have
multiple yes yes that is true and if we
see starfish that is partially
obscored by Sun partially occluded by by
sand or you know by another fish and by
the water I would still recognize that
it's that it's a starfish
um and it doesn't matter actually which
one of its arms
um is occluded or you know maybe several
arms it's a starfish yeah I agree so
there is
um something here
um on the border between these
explanations for partially occluded
objects
um and the fact that it is symmetrical
and actually there are several equally
important parts to the starfish that
make it a starfish right so what makes a
starfish a starfish or you know we can
even look at our famous pandam yeah so
what makes panda a panda so we already
saw one explanation and this is a
panda's face but maybe this is not the
only one maybe what makes panda panda
panda is that it has this particular
face or maybe that it has a tail
uh or maybe it has this floor
or a particular shape of its ears
um so just like a human would give
several explanations to the fact that it
recognizes a particular object as a
panda or a cat
our Black Box CX system should also be
capable of giving several explanations
and this of course if we want to make
sure that it classifies similar to us
humans I think this is crucial if we
want to use this black box AI systems
that they classify the recognize objects
in a similar way to us humans otherwise
how how can we use them how can we trust
them
over time we'll be able to make small
changes which will change this number
and hopefully increase it until that is
the category that is seen in the image
and not that you're completely different
or every time you call the method then
this will be less effective in some
cases then it will even slow things down
because the program will never appear to
stabilize